welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about whether or
not all avengers go to heaven
will vision burn forever in digital hell
are
any of us really alive do souls exist
that's a something to drink for
i got a soul now yeah hell yeah hey well
new rockstars is here to help you
navigate through all metaphysical
existential crises
we're gonna figure this out together i'm
eric boss here with me is tommy bechtold
how you doing buddy oh i'm doing great
uh you know they they call me the
godfather of soul they call you that
that's a title that i willingly accept
i'm a soul man through and through
it is well earned um so
one division we just learned uh not too
long ago is officially releasing january
15th
so now really its biggest mystery is how
is vision alive again after dying twice
which then you know brings up the
question was he ever really
alive in the sense of what we understand
being alive to be
how exactly was vision created what part
of vision is vision we got all these
questions
so really tommy what's the big question
that's going to condense all this
confusion for us
eric it's simple does vision have a soul
because being alive
isn't necessarily the same thing as
having a soul many of us
become soulless this time of year yes
grinches but to answer your question no
see you next week everybody oh lorne
thanks for bringing us on
uh nbc [ __ ] you guys
but uh hey this has been wild oh
yeah look there's a guy playing that
saxophone doing the same way 40 years oh
no no no
we're just kidding we're just kidding so
this question was actually inspired by
a jaisal on our discord who asked what
is the status of vision going to be
after the first season of wan division
dead or alive
well even before we get to after the
first season we're talking
during the first season to understand
wandavision and
how vision is alive again before we even
get to the metaphysics of it all
we kind of have to break down the
confusing process of visions creation
because honestly i doubt
95 percent of mcu fans could explain off
the top of their heads
even if they had the mind stone wedged
in their heads like tommy just off the
top of your head
what do you think well you know when a
mommy vision and a daddy vision are in
love
they create a sentient being
out of stark industries artificial
intelligence
and 3d printers and
much like a mr potato head it's the sum
of all the magical parts that make a
vision
nailed it thank good night everybody see
you next week great work dave chappelle
will be here
oh [ __ ] i have no idea i have no idea
right it's hard and
look i make videos about this all the
time and even still i have to go
re-watch age of ultron to be exactly
sure on how he was made so how was
vision made this is the first chapter
here well
vision was originally designed by ultron
to be ultron's final form android body
ultron used dr helen cho's human tissue
generation tech
fusing those synthetic cells with
vibranium atoms
so just right here we're building our
math formula here we got
human tissue plus vibranium great
compound starts there
but then ultron powered this body with
the mind stone which was the source of
his own artificial intelligence
tony derived remember there's that
amorphous blue ai blob
form the hollow projected to compare to
jarvis yes
that was cosmic tech derived from
infinity stone
power and that is uh that blob is what
became ultron
uh so now ultron is trying to plug in
that magic
ethernet directly into the body by
putting the stone there
at this stage we got human tissue plus
vibranium plus the mind stone now
according to ultron the final piece of
this puzzle was supposed to be
his own evolved consciousness into the
body
but that didn't get added he was
interrupted the avengers took the cradle
and then tony decided to replace what
ultron was going to put in there with
the nice peaceful os
of jarvis ah yes here we go we got human
tissue plus vibranium plus minestone
plus
jarvis that's four components but we're
not done yet because finally
thor woke up this android with a spark
of life
from mjolnir and that love tap is many
believe
or at least a big part of the reason
that vision can lift
mjolnir and they also got the name
vision canonically in the mcu
after thor's vision of vision in the
bathtub
so we got vision equals
human tissue plus vibranium plus mine
stone plus jarvis plus
asgardian magic
[Applause]
ah yes tail as old as time
in other words and this is why i have
gripes with vision for all you people
wondering why i'm always
you know being mean to him vision is
essentially all the over complicated
writing of age of ultron bottled up in a
heinz colored cluster that makes each of
those individual components
less cool so basically vision is like ah
i'm vision i'm less than the sum of my
parts
you know who i bet also hates vision
paul bettany because he went from a very
cushy voice-over job that he probably
made
a ton of money doing to having to get
practical
prosthetics and makeup put on him for
hours every day
to play this soulless suck ass character
in the mcu
just kidding guys i love him don't don't
don't come at me in the comments
i'm a viz kid all the way you know every
time paul bettany has to get that red
makeup put on he's like
my agent was able to negotiate 250 000
more per picture
just for this was it worth it yes was it
worth it
was it all worth it i don't know but
okay so now that we know how he was made
we have to ask
is this frankenstein monstrosity alive
well what makes something alive
according to biology 101
there are seven characteristics of a
living organism
one it responds to external stimuli two
it can grow and change over time three
it produces offspring okay four it
maintains a stable body temperature
that's fine not me it metabolizes energy
not very quickly six it consists of one
or more cells
that i guarantee i have and seven it is
uh capable of adapting
to its environment yes i bought a
comfortable fleece at bj's wholesale
club today
adapting to the cold temperatures i'm
alive eric i mean we know tommy's alive
this is great
you haven't passed all the turing tests
that we've run by i have not produced an
offspring but god have i tried and that
brings us to our sponsor adam and eve
and i'm just kidding
now over these seven characteristics
there is some debate in the scientific
community for example there are hybrid
animals like mules
they're sterile not a single mule can
produce an offspring so is it not an
organism well
yeah it's an organism but yeah in
general most other things without
human interference can produce offspring
and then there's the whole thing over
viruses right
so uh viruses are not cellular they
require other cells that they can hijack
and make
copies they replicate other viruses but
using the
the genetic information in those cells
but viruses do behave
similarly to other types of life so
maybe we have to broaden our
definitions of what an organism is and
there may be other things out there that
we don't know about aliens watching a
silicon-based life-forms
oh yeah hell yeah i love when aliens
watch
let's run vision through this all right
so
vision responds to stimuli like you know
when you try to pry out his mind stone
he didn't like it he doesn't like that
vision does grow and change over time
like
he grew that kate he also
changed into flesh between oh yes
infinity war
now it is uncertain if vision maintains
a homeostasis
or metabolizes anything like in uh civil
war he mentioned not really knowing what
anything tastes like he doesn't really
eat but his body does have human
cellular tissue based on helen
cho's contribution to skin grafts to him
but
uh i will say when it comes to
adaptations his uh his cape
and the fact that he is flush betany
they did appear to be adaptations
he became flesh betty to be able to
blend in when they were on the run
the kp looked at he's like oh thor has a
cape i want a cape that was a form of an
adaptation he had cape
envy which we've all we've all been
there we've all had that yeah
until we get sucked into jet engines now
paul bettany did just confirm in an
interview that
not only is vision packing there's
something down there and he can
adjust its density and it is according
to betany
purple so there you go you got a bionic
eggplant that you can now imagine
thanks paul
[Applause]
but given his incorporation of human
elements
i think we can conclude that vision
checks enough blocks even as an android
to be considered alive would you say so
is that fair i think that's a big
concession for me that i was able to
conclude at this point i agree that he's
alive
i am a little more simple-minded than
you eric so in my mind
i i always considered him alive mostly
because he died
like because he became dead he had to
have once been alive
was my kind of simple shortcut to
getting there
but uh i can't stop wondering it did
like helen cho have a say in how big
uh his package is like was there any
ever scientific debate like
we can't make him too big that's
unrealistic but we should not make him
insecure about it
so i mean stay tuned for our next week's
episode does helen show
because when she asked about whether
thor was gonna be at that party you know
she was down
and helen i expect to see you at the
party on saturday
will thor be there that's a good point
that's a good point i didn't think about
that
but i don't know tommy using your logic
um you know computers die
cell phones die true uh car batteries
die
good point so are all these things alive
maybe those things are alive maybe this
is a maximum overdrive reality and
we need to expand our definition of
whether machines can be stay away from
the vending machines if that's the case
because
it does not end well for that baseball
team if i recall correctly
but if for the sake of argument we're
going to say that he is
alive but now we have to look ahead at
wanda vision and we have to
look at things like metaphysics and
whether or not you believe vision has a
consciousness a sense of self
and a soul so really next chapter do
souls exist i like to think so but i've
dated some people that would say
otherwise
[Laughter]
and have proven to me otherwise we've
done many a comedy show in front of
audiences that would
make us think otherwise they've
destroyed souls right in front of us
i certainly felt the soul sucked out of
me right if souls can die
if souls can be obliterated from a quiet
audience
does that that must mean souls existed
to begin with
tuesday night at 8 pm in any comedy club
in hollywood will destroy
anyone's soul if it's alive so when it
comes to souls the existence just the
simple existence of a soul
is something that is hotly debated
because
there is really no real scientific
evidence of
any of us having souls now you may have
heard that whole
21 grams argument right in which this
doctor dr
duncan mcdougall in massachusetts
throughout the early 1900s
said he would weigh human bodies shortly
before and shortly after
death and conclude that there was an
unexplained difference in weight
of 21 grams which no one ever asked the
follow-up question there it's like wait
slightly before death what were you
doing with those bodies where you're
just like are you close get on the scale
quick quick i smell the [ __ ] oh good
goal date
and then he stabs them and he's like ah
twenty one grams wow
oh look at that you're losing weight
that's wonderful bye saul
have fun in heaven you're so light
you're gonna have a great summer body
but on top of that the experiments like
most experiments in the early 1900s were
[ __ ] many other scientists looking
back on this
pointed out that there's just a lot of
gaps in the research one of them being
the fact that the human body heat tends
to rise
at the moment of death due to fluids not
being cooled
uh air and blood and stuff by passing
through the lungs
and that naturally cools our our air as
it flows through so that causes the
the heat to stay where it is in the body
and it causes heat all over the body of
the bloodstream to rise
very slightly and cause slightly more
moisture evaporation
through our epidermis so that's just how
it happens and then that slight moisture
loss is
we can what account to 21 grams or so
god i wanted that to be the soul you
know we we did want it to be the soul we
wanted it to be true like many things in
the realm of belief versus science it's
just you know it informs a different
part
of our imaginations and yeah the whole
thing of a soul it's not something
that's really grounded in science anyway
it's a in religious and spiritual belief
like when we
identify who someone is their
personality or self we're not really
referring to anything grounded in
science we're referring to
maybe their memories their associations
that their brains have formed over their
lifetimes
our past inside jokes our moment of
connection
uh experiences we had together things
that inform your personality it's really
linked to your memory
and um yeah people whose brains have
been damaged by strokes
alzheimer's other diseases they are
described to have tragically
lost really their sense of self the
thing that made them them
because if you lose your memory it's
tough it's you're kind of not the same
person anymore
however i don't think it's fair to say
those people are soulless because those
people in many cases
are capable of bringing joy into the
world finding new hobbies bringing
all kinds of wonder and comfort and
they're still
people and i think we can attribute that
persistence
that that innate need for all human
beings to want to connect with each
other
as a soul if you're going to take the
religious side of it and just make it a
humanistic argument that all human
beings
want to be happy we want to connect with
each other uh we want to find these
moments of joy
even if it's not attached to a lifetime
of memories
you could say that is what a soul is
i mean it's it's how i've described it
because i've spent a lot of time
thinking about this yeah sure like
is it something that comes from heaven
maybe that's what you believe that's
totally fine
uh if it's from a higher power imbues
all of us with this
uh or it's just something that like we
discover throughout
our lives and it drives all of us
together as opposed to apart from each
other
now um the cynical problem with that
definition
is it is externally applied it is kind
of
in the eye of us observers and if you're
gonna be a jerk about it you could say
that that definition could
apply to all animals having souls and
you know some people say well my pet has
a soul my dog is going to heaven
but um you know you could personify a
jellyfish
and they aren't making cute animated
movies about all jellyfish going to have
an eric in fact
i would be pretty certain most jellyfish
go to hell where they belong
absolutely the finding nemo they they
personified all those sea creatures
not a jellyfish they were just like a
wall of stingers that almost killed dory
yeah the same could be said for any kind
of like a personality connection you
might have with
any kind of technology ai alexa
siri the robot girlfriend i built in
college she doesn't mean that baby
he doesn't mean that
[Music]
sorry she's mad now she heard what you
said
she's always hearing what i'm saying and
you know continuing the
the [ __ ] argument just because wanda
loves vision does not mean vision has
a soul a lot of people love their sex
toys and blow up dolls
that doesn't mean those things are going
to heaven you know they ain't making
through those pearly gates
i don't think my my vintage playboys are
going to be up there in my golden
condo in heaven when i die it's just a
condom
it's a beautiful golden condom i got
four
four roommates but it's a great kind
it's 450 square feet
one parking spot utilities not included
but they all have street cleaning only
once a month that's right exactly
you get it despite all this i would say
you know it's a big concession for me to
say this
i think vision's ai consciousness does
suggest he has
an inner world at least as much as the
other avengers do
that guy's capable of reasoning he's
capable of empathy you know
so what we just what we consider to be a
soul
that character in the mcu has as much of
a soul as tony stark or captain america
or
thor or nebula or gamora or thanos or
any of these people do
and if we're trying to identify what
part of vision that soul is contained in
it's obviously not the human tissue it
was just skin grafts and a petri dish
before it became a part of them
it's not the vibranium even though the
vibranium does have some spiritual
qualities it is not the vibranium
because
cap shield does not have a soul
[Music]
it's not thor's lightning though there
is magic contained in it
it is thor's lightning itself does not
contain any kind of sentience
visions itself must be somewhere between
jarvis
and the mind stone now the avengers and
shuri believed that extracting the mind
stone itself and infinity war would
preserve
vision's identity like maybe they
thought that he would have reserved
enough like soul
charge in his body so that he could live
on without his cause
but you know when thanos ripped out the
mind stone
we never really got to see whether that
would have worked uh vision
turned gray and lifeless and i would say
based on that he
clearly needed that stone yeah and if he
can rearrange his molecules and phase
shift but
not bypass the circuitry of his stone
based on that
and really the fact that paul bettany
has played vision way differently
than the way he played jarvis and we
also have to look at the fact that
vision's consciousness
return and wandavision comes with the
mind stone in his head once more if you
didn't need it why would he have it
behold the atheists nightmare i think
we have to conclude that what we
identify as vision's soul
the organic component that allows him to
grow and to change into love
is at least inextricably linked to the
mind stone
i think it's also linked to his
connection with wanda and they both had
their powers derived from that stone in
particular there's a moment in infinity
war where she can kind of sense
what the mind stone is doing and she's
like i only feel you
and i think when she says i only feel
you she's referring to that connection
through the mind stone that informs
their love i think we're gonna see more
of this in one division
so based on that the fact that the mind
stone
is objectively destroyed in the present
universe they use the stones to destroy
the stones
maybe not in an elseworld universe but
in the present mcu that means whatever
form of vision we're now seeing in one
division including what we're going to
call
his soul for argument's sake must be
a projection from within wanda's mind or
all of reality itself being manipulated
to make vision capable of existing
okay so when it comes to answering the
question of is vision really alive how
is he alive again does he have a soul
here's what we can conclude vision was
as much
alive as a virus is he
only ever had as much of a soul as a
vibrator does
and in one division he's probably
wanda's imaginary friend
you are fully functional aren't you i am
programmed in multiple techniques
oh what a cheerful little sentiment to
go into our thanksgivings
gotta go blow my brains out now
i just spent the past 15 or so minutes
finding a
metaphysical a spiritual a religious and
a scientific basis
to again insult vision's existence yeah
you got him
listen if there's one thing we can take
away from this it's [ __ ] vision forever
come as long as you want wanda because
no one's really gonna know or care
nobody got time for that wanda just do
it on your own time away from us
well uh we want to move on to some
people who helped us make this episode
starting with our friends at
coors lights so these days
everything really is go go go hustle and
bustle it's kind of a lot you need a
moment to just
turn off for a little bit that's where
our sponsor coors
light comes in handy so when i really
need to just turn off and let the day
float away
binging reality tv for 90s movies i've
seen 200 times i just want to do it all
with a coors light
born in the rocky mountains of colorado
in 1978 coors light is a refreshing
crisp in
only 102 calories coors light is brewed
with a three-step cold process so it's
actually made to chill damn
now when i'm taping this tommy it is in
the morning
but you know what uh i start my days
real early here at new rockstars
and i've been working for six hours so
it is five o'clock somewhere yeah time
to drink up and i wish i had a coors
light in front of me but i'm woefully
unprepared
but i assure you this has put a thought
into my head and much like vision
uh my soul will only be manifested by
drinking a six-pack
of coors light tonight and i might be in
the imagination of elizabeth olsen as
well
god knows i'm on her mind she must be
thinking about me i think we're
all in the imagination of elizabeth
olsen yeah she's capable of imagining
this whole world
where in her tommy westfall extended
universe yes
and we're better off for that absolutely
all right so this is why coors light is
the one we choose when uh we need a
moment of chill
so when you want to reset reach for the
beer that is made to chill
you can have coors light delivered by
going to get dot coorslight.com
and finding local delivery options near
you celebrate responsibility coors
brewing company golden colorado
dab we also want to thank our friends at
calm for helping us make this episode
one of the most powerful ways to improve
your overall health and happiness is to
get a good night's sleep but if your
daily routine has changed it could be
harder to fall and stay asleep
that is why we are excited to partner
with calm the app that is designed to
help you ease stress and get the best
sleep of your life
and when you relieve anxiety and improve
your sleep you feel better
in every part of your life palm has a
library of programs designed for healthy
sleep like soundscapes guided
meditations
and over 100 sleep stories narrated by
soothing voices like stephen fry laura
dern
doesn't that sound great call me when
they have gilbert godfrey time to go to
sleep
shut your eyes and go to bed i am iago
so over 85 million people around the
world
use calm to take care of their minds and
get better sleep
85 million people are like stephen fry
put me to bed daddy come on now
i don't need laura dern to whisper me to
sleep but i would like her to choke me
till i pass
out i don't know if that's an indictment
on calm or an advertisement for them
just a fact about me
oh and for listeners of the show calm is
offering a special limited time
promotion of 40
off all calm premium subscription at
calm.com bigquestion that is 40
off unlimited access to calm's entire
library
and new content is added every week get
started today at calm.com
bigquestion that's calm.com big question
bang
love it bang energy bang energy also
sneak in its way energy all right now we
gotta move on to a
bite-sized question that tommy's gonna
take for us you ready man yeah hell yeah
this comes from flash t-man from discord
askin
and i'm quoting him exactly so i know
the stones were destroyed in all but
the stone's abilities have also been
given to a few people
whose power is derived from the stones
also could those people being around
mean the stone's presence has never left
the universe they occupied
great questions
question from the old discord those are
my people
let's talk about this in in terms of how
we would explain it to a child
vision was powered by the minds
scarlet witch and quicksilver were
activated by the mine stone
captain marvel was powered by the space
stone
those are all infinity stone connections
we know about so far
the infinite exclusive this is what we
know the infinity stones emit gamma
radiation according to
banner and end game which let's face it
he's smart he's strong he's big let's
listen to him
i trust him and i trust you gamma
radiation compared to alpha radiation or
beta radiation you beta males
is not a particle of the radioactive
substance
but an electromagnetic wave of energy
that causes the atomic structure of its
mass
to destabilize we're getting cray-cray
with these gamma waves
so it's not like carol danvers has tiny
pieces of the space stone
floating around inside of her the space
tone radiation that washed over her was
one step removed from the space stone
itself and that radiation in her cells
is not infectious with the same cosmic
energy that direct exposure
to the stone would give so it's uh you
know she's like got a dusting of space
stone energy on her
right right right you know like me i
have a dusting of crystal meth on me at
all times
and that's what makes me so vibrant it's
like glitter you can't get rid of it
that's right
and it's great for crafting so well we
may learn that mcu characters possess
powers that were derived from the
infinity stones no new cases of stone
produced powers
are going to occur going forward the
stones are destroyed reduced to atoms
they're done that's it no new cases we
don't have the data
you can't prove to me the stones are
infecting people right now the stones
are a hoax
it's like saying like oh i got uh warmed
by a light bulb you know so like i'm
still feeling a bit warm
and the light bulb itself is gone yes
it's like yeah i might still feel warm
yeah it might be warmer overall going
forward yes but like i
i that doesn't mean pieces of that light
bulb are
breathed in and in my lungs and
destroying my lung tissue yeah i'm just
remembering moments that we had
lightsaber duels with the
you know those two hell yeah absolutely
so we'll see i mean maybe some
flashbacks right we might see some
flashbacks and reveal other characters
like i was created with the power stone
years ago i mean it's a it's a comic
book movie
things can come back and go away and be
changed and be
explained in in a matter of minutes we
can go from having one thing be an
absolute truth to another thing so
the best answer is probably as of right
now it's done
ask me in two movies so as much of uh
something's radiation could exist in the
universe does not mean that thing itself
is still around right in the universe
great question
uh and we have time for one final box
craps question
have uh never not funny
it's good staying true to this idea of
whether or not vision
is an animated object or whether he's a
self and a soul
have you ever given a possession an
inanimate object
an identity or personality you know i'm
not like
a big name your car and give them a
gender and like slap your boat on the
ass and call her good girl or anything
like that but like
i have i've assigned like temperaments
to things
like oh that tv is stubborn okay so my
uncle
michael bob has this theory that you
have to be gentle with slot machines in
order to get them to pay out
he's like you can't push the buttons or
pull the arm hard
it won't pay that way you have to pull
it like gingerly
and make sure that the machine is not
agitated because they
punish you for doing that i would say
that's the closest thing i've given
an identity or personality to i've
certainly assigned like luck
to items you know like but i would say
mainly anything i i give a possession an
identity or personality to
is to explain its shitty behavior oh my
computer keeps overheating because it's
so turned on by all the porn i watch or
something like that
i don't know what about you um i used to
really be into legos as a kid
i was one of the kids who had like an
entire table in his room that was just
for a lego metropolis that i built like
i had a city and i would i was the kind
of kid who didn't go
just get the cool new lego ships that
they would because they started these
star wars legos
when i was a kid but like i would i
would be like
do you have any legos that are just a
city block street
flat do you have like a cul-de-sac
honestly yeah and i'd be like ooh we
gotta go to this walmart because this
walmart
specifically has like you know though
180 by 180 yeah
uh one and i would get so excited when i
saw this i'm like yes and again i can
expand my city now
and i would just get like the little
baby crates because they just had raw
bricks in there
because otherwise you gotta find you
know bricks from other things right
yeah i was an idiot but like i would
build this town out i'm like this will
be
a city hall this will be a veterinarian
office
uh and i like started to do city
planning uh and anytime i got in fights
with my sister she would take one look
at that and be like all right and just
swipe off the table because she knew i
would spend
hours yes this is the mayor this is his
stepdaughter
he's not the mayor is being indicted on
racketeering charges right now
yeah and she could hear me muttering to
myself
big time like self-talker when it came
to toys when i was a kid like
whole elaborate scenarios uh i had like
a weird thing where there was like um
a part of like i couldn't fit my entire
town on the desk so i had to do like uh
my nightstand and i put like another
little town over here and i'm like oh so
this is a colony
so i wonder if this colony will be
granted independence from the homeland
so i was like but i don't want them to
go to war with each other because this
colony doesn't have any ships they're
gonna get decimated right so i created
this whole back and forth of like
diplomatic uh peace negotiations
we don't have the military
infrastructure to defend themselves eric
they need to use diplomacy i think the
peace truce came from the fact that they
were willing to supply
a mineral or a certain amount of their
gdp every year to the homeland that they
could be
you know so the fact that i had this
level of societal structure that was all
in my mind palace my sister knew that
and she knew like at any point
she could go in there and just like
godzilla knocked something out
and at one point it was like it reached
the you know roman peak of its
civilization
at some point where i had skyscrapers
and i had like bridges connecting the
skyscraper to monorail system
in there and she i can't remember what
it was i think i ate a couple cookies
that she told me i wasn't allowed to eat
and she came in she's like did you eat
them and i said no no no
knowing me i was probably a little
[ __ ] i was like why i ate him so you
didn't have to eat him fatty or
something her
i shouldn't have done that no no no she
wrecked it and i remember
seeing the town mayor just like in the
wreckage
fiddling as the town burned
coughing up blood like eric even jess
avengers don't let our deaths be in vain
eric
and then he expired and his eyes just
went like in the lego movie
and then i went over i think i grabbed a
chair and i chased my sister in the
house
yes yes chair shots wwf style
[Applause]
so i think at that point it's just like
all right no more also i'm in like
eighth grade and i'm having like um
girls visiting at my house now right
right right it's for the best
she actually did you a favor by
destroying your cities she so i put them
all like in a crate and then but i kept
like my lego x-wing i'm like
it's still cool to have this of course
that's a collector's item eric you must
that's how i justify a house full of
baseball cards and action figures at 37
years old
i'm not [ __ ] toys this is iron man
okay
well now that we're adults um doing nerd
things we can it's okay to buy
toys yes it's kind of okay to buy toys
and fill our rooms with it yeah
like absolutely my sister isn't allowed
in here she's no she can't hurt you
anymore eric
you're safe here no girls allowed all of
our toys are alive and they thank us for
keeping them safe including vision
that is it for this episode of the big
question
uh tommy thanks so much for joining this
episode it's been a great chat
my pleasure i'm glad we ended on a happy
note because i was really full of
existential dread after the
the big question was answered uh you can
follow tommy at tommy bech told follow
me at ea voss follow new rockstars
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification bell
and subscribe to the big question
podcast feed wherever your podcasts
be kind leave us a nice rating and
review and uh you can support this
channel get lots of great gift options
at our merch store including this hi
i'm eric vosh shirt yeah this is a good
one
now people know me as i'm walking around
with a mask on
outside they'll still be able to
recognize me with this shirt and they
can recognize you as eric voss if you i
can't wait i'm gonna
i'm gonna be ordering one uh asap get on
it
you can get all this including a ton of
great designs at new rockstarsmerch.com
tommy see you next time buddy bye
goodbye
[Music]
you